everyone misses their shots now and
again even the sharpest of shooters
throw away three kills because of
momentary lapses in concentration
Smith's good position for price there's
nothing you could say would be very
difficult he doesn't have like any time
to work with the bomb pence could take
five seconds alone he's gonna go for it
behind the fountain caricatures gonna
charge him down is it miss quite a few
pistol shots Kenny yes he wanna kill the
round but what if these events weren't
just anomalies what if your erratic aim
was so consistent that it became your
trademark well in the unfortunate case
of a certain csgo player that's exactly
what happened this two on three
favoring them at the moment Drake and
missing a big shot at he can't get the
follow-up so track it now still holding
off backside of banana crush wants to
work in that direction and oh my
goodness 30-degree windowed racket how
did that miss William Drakon Sundin
stands out as exceptional but for almost
all of the wrong reasons his reputation
is CS goes most notorious serial whiffer
man started as just a playful community
meme but it might have actually
contributed to the derailment of what
looked like a promising career so why
can't this guy keep his eye on the prize
and will he ever find his way back into
the upper echelon of CS co alright so if
you aren't familiar with track and story
here is everything you need to know the
man has gorgeous hair and a legion of
ravenous fans that are obsessed with it
so it all fans wanted to know how you
get your hair like it is there any
secrets
there's no pair questions on top of
being recognized for having a glorious
flow Drakken is also known for his
boundless confidence here we have a
little Sweden I think that's what they
call you
yeah well the girls called me big Sweden
okay fair enough so it's no surprise
that over the years that self-belief has
found its way into his play where he's
built up quite a reputation for hitting
some obscenely disgusting flicks and now
duration has to do it again in a 1 on 2
and he's got no grenades yeah this is
just about all over isn't it no kit
either and now both Moe's back with the
ankle there this should be impossible
from the way that's the nice flick
though but still with the 10-second he's
gotta find Hobbit off to the left Oh
what is that flick for Dracon absolutely
inhuman isn't it initially Dragons CS
journey began on a variety of smaller
Swedish rosters most notably cringe gods
who were later picked up by epsilon
eSports and during this period he really
began to make a name for himself not be
nuked if we need it this bracket once
again single-handedly carrying his team
through round 24 but dragons big break
came in March 2017 when he was picked up
by ninjas in pyjamas now at first he hit
the ground running
so dragon in for the clutch against
three oh I see Dunn knew exactly where
mr. Joplin was hiding and now it's gonna
play close with the orb never all too
comfortable for an all purple makes it
look easy to stop for dragon there you
go explosive this they're gonna ruin
that eco territory and it's a sick thing
- oh man the rest of an IP to rotate
round is Drac and who could be the
linchpin here come on out through ramp
you're trying to hold the fort in CT
fools to tracking from ramp that
completely unaware as to where that was
though catches our second is Freddie now
hits the deck it's relaxed her to 1 B 3
and Drakon this man is on fire gets
himself a third the hat-trick his break
Navi here and they pretty much wrap it
all up but it's all down to drink it
first find is successful one simple AWP
still in position bombs are planted flag
catch him he's got the book down flee me
that the hero play but being the primary
operon a historic counter-strike org
like ninjas in pyjamas meant that
there'd be more focused on dragons
individual play and it wasn't long
before people began to notice a
particular glaring hole in his game like
dragon especially has looked pretty good
in the team he does seem like he's very
weird and as much as like when you watch
him play it's almost like he only hits
the impressive shots but forest is there
to put it back on the deck miss job
dragon you know no he's out toward the
chicken coop but he's got problems
because they're flooding in Oh dragon no
dragon that's three sitting infront of
this cross there he misses the flick as
well this could be the round
nobody piece distilled slightly from
position they're going that way he's
little backs away mate it's dead all
shot that he desperately needed and he
needed the other one as well in between
both times and he's off in time and get
right found he's a sitting duck it's all
gone so many opportunities that he just
couldn't find the shots he needed this
well this is the thing because he's
gonna expect that he's still behind the
hot does he check underneath or not
[Music]
doesn't it all you're right I wouldn't
use quickscope why wouldn't you just
click why wouldn't you click - I just
discount that I run past you you know
that's one of those things that you hate
to see with some of these offers you
know that are so inconsistent and are so
flashy at times but when they're not and
we saw it now two maps in a row for
Dragon he is a liability for his team as
a primary warrant he has pool games like
that and some decision-making like we
just saw dragon was an enigma he was
equally capable of producing both
mind-blowing magic and forehead slapping
catastrophes never wins this easy missed
taught men again drops down and I'm not
sure why and as a result fans were quick
to dub his bizarre flick to whiff ratio
drakken's 30 degree window that's right
after years of living and breathing the
CS grind dragon had made his way unto a
big team only to be turned into a
community-wide meme reddit experts and
backseat hltv offers might have been
perpetuating the ridicule but eventually
it became inescapable for Dragon and
he's knows there's gonna be two there
now because the calls come in that
they've reboosted Chuck stops to
drinking a great first shot to find body
but apparently chalks is in the 30
degree window that drinkin does not eat
and get another defuse 8 to 3 now for
Jitsu okay so you're probably wondering
why does this keep happening to Dragon
and is this 30 degree window thing real
or is it all in his head but instead of
speculating like everyone else we
consulted Andrew Latham and Madison
Clark Kowski experts who study gamer
brains for a living so one way to think
of a video game play and one of the
improvements it gives you is it improves
your attention and in particular visual
attention and one way to kind of grasp
it simply is to think of visual Latinas
are like a searchlight and so one thing
we know our video game players is that
their searchlights much bigger they can
track more things in it and they can
also disregard many more kind of
irrelevant things in it as well and
there are two types of control of this
can't search light there's a kind of
internally director control but there's
another kind of control that conversely
and sunsets makes them better at certain
tasks that can also make them worse than
normal people and
the kinds of tasks it's called exogenous
attention it's where the environment
kind of captures the searchlight and
shoots it somewhere video game players
and sometimes have their attention
captured by things outside their
searchlight much much more strongly than
kind of ordinary people but funnily
enough in certain circumstances that
kind of level of kind of attentional
capture by the environment can actually
make performance worse for things kind
of in their kind of central field of
view so it might in some case just be
that he much more strongly his attention
captured by things and its periphery and
it's much stronger my relative to other
professional players which means that at
least when you compare his gun
performance in this kind of central
field of view it might come out looking
much much worse something like that
might come down to training and learning
and how Dracon interacts with the game
rather than something inherent elata no
physiological about him it also might
come down to selective attention and
that can lead to something like
inattentional blindness where you might
miss something directly in front of you
because you focused above all else on
one task one activity or one action that
you're you're performing or that you're
interested in so it could be that this
is what's happening with draken that
he's missing the the play of sitting
right in front of them because he's so
focused on making the peripheral shots
or looking for flankers are looking for
someone emerging in his periphery but
unfortunately for Dragan counter-strike
is a results-driven to business being
memed on by the community is one thing
but if your performances are hampered
with a litany of whiffed shots that end
up costing your team the round it's hard
to shake the target that you've put on
your own back
I went bro like I cannot have these easy
miss shots that I should hit but I also
would say like when I'm on my game I
probably have one of the most like
highest peaks in CS performance right so
I'm really like heaven or hell you know
it's either Dom shots are really really
[ __ ] sick but some shots I can really
miss and and it can look really bad but
then I can have everyone misses their
shots I guess I'll just be the lucky one
that it's got the 30 degree beam now
it's not entirely clear whether the 30
degree window or the pressure it put on
Drakon is ultimately what cost him his
spot on nip but since his initial
departure from the Oregon 2018 his
career has been in a constant state of
flux and no matter where he's gone
Drakken has never been able to shake the
curse of his 30 degree window down so
track it now still holding off backside
of banana crush wants to work in that
direction and oh my goodness 30 degree
window jacket how did that miss a little
good test is ready still on this prank
and ancients watching for a dragon miss
shot does he get a second chance no
tecna's takes them away it's just a
full-on fast push towards his face night
from optic drakken's got to support it
that well call for a row team we can
already see people shifting off of that
b bomb site but they gotta come quick
because i think you're diving in through
smudged racket caught on the truck and
he'll pay the price of his life because
will Drake and Nell peek from the
right-hand side yes it sure moves the
bullet somehow she's going all over the
place with his bullets it is even dying
in the end but despite the frustration
of his current situation dragon doesn't
let it get him down
he loves Counter Strike and he's as
dedicated as ever to grinding his way
back to the top my mango now from here
on first is I'm gonna keep on playing CS
and then I keep on trying and working on
myself outside and inside the game as
much as I can and hopefully I will get
back to
where I feel I belong and according to
our experts his optimism isn't
unwarranted the 30 degree window isn't
some incurable career-ending illness but
one that can be treated with the right
approach there is this tendency for
people if they play for eight hours a
day they might not learn as much as
someone who plays for eight hours a day
but also takes breaks through review
pods in between and to assess their
behavior and to watch other people and
see how they play so taking a more
practiced or a more mindful approach to
practice learning and and focusing on
what he's doing I think it could help 24
years of age Drakken still has plenty of
time to put the 30 degree window behind
him he obviously has the market cornered
on nice hair he just needs to groom his
crosshair game to match it and sure the
30 degree window isn't likely to
disappear overnight
but even Drakon understands that the
first step to solving a problem is
admitting that you have trained is every
single day you'll probably develop a 30
degree window as well and flick like
[ __ ] that's it nice but even dragging
himself seems to know but even Drakon
understands that the first step to
solving a problem is admitting that you
have won Yeah right
home jackets relapse again mrs. Affleck
[ __ ] you [ __ ] a whiffer what are you
whipping huh where is it shall we